-Performing "YAH Know,"
once again, Chance the Rapper!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ How will I
know, know, know? ♪
♪ How will I
-Liberation!
♪ Gun to ya back like Harriet ♪
♪ If you can't shoot,
can't carry it ♪
♪ If ya too fake,
can't ferry it ♪
♪ Come carry me home,
sweet chariot ♪
♪ Everybody wanna come
drive the boat ♪
♪ But nobody
wanna come paddle boat ♪
♪ If we realized
we was all compatible ♪
♪ We could combine the money,
maybe come buy the boat ♪
♪ Sometime, gun might bust ♪
♪ Bust ♪
♪ Freedom is a must ♪
♪ In Yah we trust ♪
♪ Hold my hand if you scared ♪
♪ Hold my hand if you cried ♪
♪ Hold my hand and I'll drive ♪
♪ Close your eyes,
and I'll steer ♪
♪ I'm not woke, I'm just tired ♪
♪ I'm not floatin', I'm flyin' ♪
♪ I'm not broken, I'm fine ♪
♪ I'm outspoken, I stay on code
when I'm out
in the open online ♪
♪ They gon' know
what we know in no time ♪
♪ They gon' go in the show
with no line ♪
♪ With a pick for a comb,
the clothes, the whole nine ♪
♪ Better hold on tight,
no time to slow down ♪
♪ Ask, "Are we there?",
you slept the whole time ♪
♪ You'll know
when we get there ♪
-♪ How will I know? ♪
-♪ You'll know it ♪
♪ How will I know? ♪
-♪ You'll see it ♪
-♪ But I know we'll get there ♪
♪ How will I know? ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
♪ Front to the back, get loud ♪
♪ Ones in the back, get loud ♪
♪ Run and the gun click, pow ♪
[ Gunshot ]
♪ One big crowd ♪
♪ One big smile ♪
♪ Money in one big pile ♪
♪ Blueprints in
an unzipped file ♪
♪ Akwaaba, medaase,
that's the end of my speech ♪
♪ Tell 'em, "Spread the word
from Osu to Kumasi" ♪
♪ This for Dr. Kwame,
Selassie, and Nnamdi ♪
♪ Tell 'em, "Free the youth
or we gon' free the army" ♪
♪ Can't no man can harm me,
can't no man can harm me ♪
♪ I can't let you starve me,
I can't go out like Gandhi ♪
♪ Say less, bro, we on the way ♪
♪ Star Line Fest,
hoe, we on the way ♪
♪ Better open that whole damn
street on the way ♪
♪ 'Fore it look like
"World War Z" on the gate ♪
♪ You'll know when
we get there ♪
-♪ How will I know? ♪
-♪ You'll know when
we get there ♪
♪ You'll know when
♪ You'll know ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-♪ How will I know? ♪
-Wake up!
♪ But I know we'll get there ♪
-♪ Look ♪
♪ Let me take y'all
back like Marcus ♪
♪ When Europe was
still in the darkness ♪
♪ Our boats was
big as the ark is ♪
♪ The cargo
was gold-tip spears,
and it sold by the load
and it opened the market ♪
♪ Before currency,
the Canary Current made trade,
and maize was the harvest ♪
♪ Back to the
wall like the art is ♪
♪ I lean on the
crib like the mortgage ♪
♪ I breathe on the game
like a cartridge ♪
♪ I'm sorry,
I ain't mean to restart it ♪
♪ Chano got the keys
to the starship ♪
♪ With his heart on his sleeve
like a card trick ♪
♪ Goin' back to the sea
like a warship ♪
♪ Then I'm back to the sand
like a starfish ♪
♪ Mama, you don't always
have to hit the streets ♪
♪ We must fight, but you must
fight to go protect your peace ♪
♪ And I'm gon' ride,
but when you ride with me,
you'll get some sleep ♪
♪ And we gon' mob,
but when we mob,
it'll be lil' more discreet ♪
-♪ How will I know? ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
-♪ You'll know when
we get there ♪
-♪ How will I know? ♪
-♪ You'll know ♪
♪ Ha, ha! ♪
♪ You'll know ♪
-♪ How will I know? ♪
-♪ You'll know ♪
-♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
-Liberation!
-♪ At the break of dawn,
we gon' make a break,
we gon' take the farm ♪
♪ Take the safe,
we finna break the bank,
replace the tapes
and made fake alarms ♪
The home team waitin',
know we comin' over,
got a Sauvignon Blanc
with the two cigars ♪
♪ Case you was stoppin'
to loot the bar,
we got valet waitin' with
a souped-up car ♪
♪ Got a nitro boost for
the chasin' ♪
♪ Got a few rooms
booked at the Days Inn ♪
♪ Got a lil' bit of Mace
and a lil' bit of mash
just in case
catch a glimpse of the faces ♪
♪ Good God,
this the heist for the ages ♪
♪ From the cages,
straight to the Majors ♪
♪ Liberation,
you gotta take it ♪
♪ Free yourself,
learned that from the Haitians ♪
♪ Smile through the tears,
learned that from a crocodile ♪
♪ Free your mind like
a pocket dial ♪
♪ I got fully auto
rocket power ♪
♪ So any damn door,
it'll knock it down ♪
♪ Just call my phone
when you make it down ♪
♪ Just give me a piece
when you break it down ♪
♪ Cullinan Diamond
when I take the crown ♪
♪ 'Cause when I take the crown,
I'mma break the crown ♪
♪ You'll know ♪
-♪ Don't wanna think too much ♪
♪ Don't wanna think about it ♪
♪ But I know we will get there ♪
-♪ Yah know ♪
-♪ I don't wanna think
too much ♪
♪ Don't wanna think about it ♪
-♪ But I know we gonna
get there ♪
-♪ How will I know? ♪
-♪ You'll know when
we get there ♪
♪ You'll know when
-♪ How will I know? ♪
-Liberation!
-♪ How will I know
when we get there? ♪
-♪ You'll know ♪
-♪ How will I know? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]